it's day 13 day 14 15 probably something
like 15 never know and day it is I think
Michelle is at improv watching improv
somewhere I think still haven't done any
Christmas shopping I'm not done no I'm
like I got my parents a gift card for
ballroom dancing lessons
so gifts like this is good on to so many
levels one because they watch Dancing
with the Stars constantly they talk
about Dancing with the Stars constantly
they love dancing my association to it
gives them a chance to make other
friends with other couples they live in
a retirement community and neither of
them are retired it's hard for them to
make friends with people of their own
age and of their own physical capability
level 3 I get some out of the house
those are heavens when you buy a big TV
they watch TV all the time every
possible reality TV show one of their
favorite pastimes is analyzing the
people who are on those reality shows
and sometimes making fun of the people
which is kind of ironic that they're
sitting on their couch watching people
do stuff in real life and they're making
fun of them while they sit on their
couch and watch it but I love my parents
and that's why I got them this gift card
whether they like it or not I'm forcing
them to make friends just kind of ironic
that I'm forcing my family to make
friends and I'm vlogging vlogging
doesn't make you friends we've had some
very interesting comments Gracie you
remind me of Hermione from Harry Potter
dot dot accept all grown up dot kinda I
take that as a compliment one I love
Harry Potter - I do think that sometimes
I look like Hermione and three I respect
her unending pursuit of knowledge so
vlogging will make you friends if that's
where this was supposed to be going